And the one that I think is best is the next day procedure. This is sort of the
most important thing to make the solution work. If we can't do this, then we
would need to think of a different approach. And the reason that I think this is
best is that, we can solve this in a simple way for the simple case, which is
what we'll do next, not worrying about the complexity of how many days are in
different months. And get a good feeling that we're able to get close to the
right answer for some cases. The other answer that I think would be okay is
doing is leap year. This is something we know we're going to need at some point.
We need to determine whether the years are leap years to know how many days
there are in the month of February but it's kind of a grungy, painful thing to
write. It's something we know we're going to be able to do. And it's something
that's not too interesting, so we're going to leave that until later. You could
certainly make a case for doing that first. The other two are really not good
answers. Trying to do the whole problem at this point is a little early. We
still want to break it down into simpler parts and make progress and know that
we're making progress. That other one is closer to something very small. The
problem is this is probably not really the procedure that we want and until we
write these other procedures and think more about how we're going to do this, we
might not know enough to implement this correctly. And the reason that I'm going
to suggest that this is not what we want is the number of days in a month
actually depends on the year, if the month is February. So let's start by
writing the next day procedure, and to keep things simple we'll assume that all
months have 30 days.